there's this misconception about luck I
mean there's people that don't like the
word luck if if somebody says you know
hey I think you became successful in
business because you got lucky and
people get upset at that but the reality
of it is yes
the bigger of a business or the more of
success you wanna have a life
you better believe you want luck on your
side and there's a formula on how to get
lucky okay so let's talk about that
today there's a formula on how to get
lucky the one thing I can tell you is
80% of people in the world 80% of people
are in reaction mode all their lives 80%
are reacting what does that mean we get
a bill a bill comes in for mortgage or
house or rent we react we pay the bill
right we have something that happens we
save money we react we pay the bill
generally you hear when people say
people are three paychecks away from
being broke you've heard these stats
many times by Money Magazine fortune
Forbes you are three paychecks away from
being homeless or you're three paychecks
away from this because we're constantly
living in reaction mode I get a job
because I pay the bills I am reacting to
the bills right 15% of people are
initiators what is an initiator an
initiator is somebody that takes the
initiative to go out there and get a job
they take the initiative to create a
resume to to give it to a boss and they
get a reaction from the boss right they
initiate a sale they initiate a contact
they initiate to meet with somebody
they're constantly initiating then there
is creation 5% are in the creation mode
and to be in the creation mode i'll give
you ideas about what the creation mode
is creation mode is amazon creates an
idea a campaign and they say if you buy
this you get 20% off today
great then they initiate they make the
initiative to send us the message and
they send an email to all the prime
users then we react to it right they
create a campaign then they initiate a
contact to us we react to it all of us
in one way or another were reactors
there's nothing wrong with being a
reactor
kid is sick we're going to react to when
family some happens we're going to react
to it the key to creating your own luck
and getting lucky is to constantly be in
creation mode you get a constantly be in
creation mode for instance somebody that
says I want to create a list of 17
people that I want to go sell a house to
these are celebrities I want to have on
my resume that I sold the house to these
celebrities if you create the contact
just because you created that content
list contact list doesn't mean you
already have luck because some people
are afraid of initiating that creation
so you create the contact then you
initiate then you're going to get a
reaction from those 17 people somebody
might say I want to have a meeting with
you know a celebrity I want to go out
there meet with this one person I think
that person is going to do that I want
to go recruit this person I want to go
do business with this person no problem
you created that idea now you got to
initiate now you got to react the
challenge is if you want to have luck on
your side you got to make sure you are
constantly in creation mode you are
constantly creating opportunities and
initiating them with the hopes of
getting reaction the more you create the
more you initiate the more reaction
you'll get that's my message as an
entrepreneur on how to get lucky and if
you missed last week's video on how to
stand up a stand out on social media as
an entrepreneur click on the link to
watch the video how to stand out on
social media as an entrepreneur thanks
for watching